[Music]  let's play some basketball  you  what's going on here why Michael I  taught you'd never ask  you see these aliens come from outer  space and they want to make a slaves in  their theme park yeah what do we care  they're little so we challenge them to a  basketball game but then they show up  and they ain't some little thank-yous  they're monsters let myself  we need to beat these guys what I'm  trying to say is we need your  [Music]  perhaps I could be of some assistance  [Music]  how did you get here anyway producers a  friend of mine just to her team sure  come and drop me off here  ah I like how it goes  [Music]  three muggle wish they'd never been born  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you